Son presented a very natural approach to
fragment assembly.
I, on the other hand, will present a very
unnatural approach to genome assembly.
And we will debate later whose approach is
better.
The first thing to notice that in fact,
there
are two Hamiltonian paths in the graph
that Son presented.
This is the first one and this is the
second one.
And while Son presented his very natural
approach, it's
absolutely unclear how to find either of
these paths.
I will do something different.
First, I will slightly modify the graph.
Remember, in the Hamiltonian path problem,
we put 3-mers into nodes
of the graph.
In contrary, I will represent every edge
of my graph as a 3-mer.
See this almost cosmetic difference.
It's not clear why do I care so much about
this difference at the moment.
If we label the edges of the graph, let's
also try to label nodes of the graph.
And how should we label the nodes of
the edge TAA?
Let's label the starting node by the
prefix of TAA.
And let's label the ending node by the
suffix of TAA.
As a result we will have this graph, shown
below here, it's a path currently not a
graph yet.
And this is our starting point, this path
labeled by 3-mers,
where edges are labeled by 3-mers and
nodes are labeled by 2-mers.
And now we'll do something really strange
with this graph.
Let's glue identically labeled nodes in
the graph.
In this graph, we have three nodes labeled
AT.
Let's glue them together.
Let's bring two of them next to each
other.
And next,
let's bring three of them next to each
other.
Let's bring them even closer to each
And finally, they will glue in a single
vertex as shown at this slide.
Now, we haven't done yet, because there
are more identically labeled nodes on this
graph.
Here it is, three nodes labeled TG.
Let's bring them closer together.
And finally, they will be glued into the
same node.
Are we done?
Not yet, there are two more nodes that
identically labeled.
Those are two nodes GG.
Bring them closer together and glue them
in a single node.
The result is the graph that we will be
study in
this lecture.
It is called De Bruijn Graph of a string.
And the question that we first should ask,
how does this graph
can help us to find the genome.
Where is the genome hiding in this graph?
It isn't hiding at all.
Because we started from the genome to
construct this graph.
We just made some operations to make the
genome
somewhat illusive in this graph, but it is
there.
It was always there.
Let's take a look.
What corresponds to the genome in this
graph?
Of course, it is the part that we were
gluing,
that goes like this.
This, this, this, and this
path
along the graph is slowly but surely
builds
the string, the original string that was
used.
Let's continue doing this.
Continue doing this.
Well, what are we trying to do?
Well, since we need to explain all
3-mers in the graph, what we are trying to
do is to find a path
in the graph that visits every edge 3-mer
exactly once.
Let's continue.
And after we finish this, we construct
actually something that we call an
Eulerian path.
The path that visits every edge in the
graph exactly once.
And now we have eulerian path problem that
is attributed to Euler, of course.
Find an Eulerian path in the graph which
is a path visiting every node exactly
once.
And as you remember, Euler solved this
problem
by trying to solve the Seven Bridges of
Konigsberg problem.
This is an ancient map of Konigsberg.
And the orange dot on this map is exactly
where I took you to the field-trip.
Now what Euler did, he constructed a graph
by
connecting four nodes in the graph, each
node corresponds
to a district of the city.
By an edge, if there is a corresponding
bridge between these two districts in the
city.
It is an undirected graph in difference from
directed graphs that we
mainly consider in this lesson but it
doesn't matter that much.
The differences between directed and
undirected graphs are small,
and we will be mainly working with these
directed graphs.
And we'll let you a chance to
implement whatever other problems for
for undirected graph.
so we now have two problems.
Eulerian path problem and Hamiltonian path
problem.
Do you find many differences here?
And the question arises, why did I waste
your time reformulating the problems that
Son already presented?
What was my goal?
And in
the next segment, I'll give the answer to
this question